it is so
glad you had me on your show you said
you're not under being here
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Karen Culkin he's
I mean nominated actor you know as Roman
boy on but for my money is the best show
on television HBO's succession which
returns for its fourth and final season
on March 26th here in Culkin welcome to
the show thanks for having me how are
you around spicy food before we get
started I have no idea I don't really
eat spicy food I don't know if it I
think it's because I tend to not like it
I don't know if that I have no idea what
my threshold is none whatsoever well
then I guess today we'll put a real
number to it hate that let's do it so
scary
[Music]
classic chili maple
cheers
well that's lovely
[Music]
so this forthcoming season of succession
marks the last final go-round with the
Roy family and I'm curious at the end of
a run like this what's your relationship
with leaving a character like Roman
behind is it at all a relief or does the
whole thing just feel like a funeral
our last day of shooting was just a
little over two weeks ago and I I feel
like I've just been home and I've been
busy and I haven't had time to process
it yet I'm sure something like
depression is gonna hit at some point
I feel like I really really know this
guy and it's so much fun to play him and
at the same time I didn't want to do it
forever I didn't want to get to a place
where I was bored with it but I guess I
just
it to me it feels like there's so much
more I wanted to do which is probably a
good thing instead of the opposite which
is feeling like okay I've done this
already
um
that's not you know right kind of like
me with just the 20 Seasons
I'm on the other side of the spectrum
you know I'm like this thing's working
for me you know like let's just crank
let's just do it forever well that's I
was so but then if it ended right now
how do you think you would feel if you
were just at the place where it was like
you're just getting going yeah and it's
feeling really good no maybe I wouldn't
even know who I was you know when you do
it wow so long eight years you said
three years yeah and like developmental
kind of years maybe at all and I'm like
well who even am I yeah you know that
sounds about right and I've been at this
for like six and a half you count the
pilot so yeah I guess it's sort of a
little bit of that same page same
wavelength yeah all right are you ready
to move on here to Sauce number two what
do we got shaquanda's Banshee Ranch I
love the name let's go it Banshee Ranch
oh that's lovely wow
sorry I'm gonna do another does that
mean you yep that means me too sorry
your colon
[__] up
from an actor's perspective what's the
most unforgivable thing an audience
member can do during a live stage
performance
I once I didn't play my first play I was
like 17 and admittedly was
not good let's say and I could tell it
was but it was also my first play and I
was excited and I liked it it was a
little bit like every time the audience
was in I had this feeling of like I know
this isn't good
but I like it so shut up
um there's a little bit of that feeling
and the play I have this like monologue
sitting at the edge of the stage God
when I think about this this is really
not a good play
I was sitting at the end of the stage I
had to give this monologue and it's
written I take this long pause and it
was a matinee there was this old lady in
front of me and I guess I just took an
extra long pause I just left it there
and she went is that the end
and it just echoed and I I just
responded I went no
[Music]
and then felt like really sorry like God
yeah I shouldn't take a pause these
people want to get out of this play
they've been sitting here for an hour
and a half it's time to go you're right
I'll speed it up
you know whose episode I haven't seen
Michael Sarah who was really excited
this is our youth by the way uh in the
Australian one two yeah and the Chicago
one and the New York
he figured out Warren son of a [__]
um
but he was like kind of nervous and he
was really excited to do the show I
still haven't watched his episode but
when it was done I was like how was he
was like you I was like how are the
wings I wasn't yeah he was uh famously
wholly unaffected yeah I mean like just
it seems like they're just plain wings
with no sauce on it Sarah's episode
Jenna Ortega recently okay uh Halle
Berry and Lord are like the four
episodes that's like my Mount Rush no
[__] like did we forget to Sauce the
wings
yeah well he's also wildly competitive
but sort of um under the yeah under the
radar sort of just I'll teach him a game
that I've been playing for years and be
like here I'll sort of teach you how to
play it'll go easy on you and then he
whoops my ass and I can never beat him
again like he's just that guy uh he's
plays like every instrument and he
taught himself how
handles the wings
beneath you know it's like the guy can't
stop him stop being perfect yeah come on
Michael
get out of here fired
without thinking about it too much do
you have an all-time favorite Roman
expletive from the first three seasons
this is a YouTube show so you can't let
it fly okay [__] shitness uh let's a
recent one we're talking about Sandy
Furness whose health is waning not doing
too well and it said totally forgot
about this line and that it existed was
in the show I say like see Sandy is
barely alive you can tell him to go
[__] eat his own diaper and his only
response would be
I'm like damn that's brutal tell him to
go and I love to like the way it was
written to be like he doesn't know what
he's gonna say like go [__] himself go
eat his own diaper is brilliant to say
about a man who's on the way out cool
so that one
[Music]
I'm gonna sorry I'm gonna eat the whole
thing you know what I already beat you
to it because I see the pace that you're
setting here already I didn't go back
for a second bite of this which wasn't
really um
purpose
I'll finish it later
I've just got like a sweetness to it
yeah and maybe even like kind of a step
down from the last one a little bit yeah
yeah we're like shifting a little bit
shifting shifting shifted yeah
so you've been to an estimated nine
wrestlemanias does being a performer
yourself
which wrestler do you think would have
been the most successful on Broadway oh
Batista was sort of like he was sort of
decent as a wrestler that I thought
didn't have like
the most appealing like screen presence
as a wrestler and then I saw him in um
Guardians of the Galaxy and he blew me
away I was like this guy's so funny
where the hell was this guy I guess he
just the character he was playing as a
wrestler didn't have much humor to him
and wasn't really that alive and then it
was because that's the thing too with
wrestling is like once you find your
character that's the character you play
for 30 years that's it you don't really
like there can be some Evolution but
that's sort of it whereas like then
Batista got to play someone else and he
was great at that and I've seen him in a
few things since and he's really good
they just didn't see that because of the
character he chose to play as a wrestler
yeah kind of cool
wait they got some smoked around
I think I like hot sauce I think you do
too that's good to know because I got a
whole box of this [__] at home now
you're gonna have more you're gonna have
two boxes yeah
by the time this interview is over sure
sorry Colin
you have a new favorite
this in the Banshee Ranch there we go
says the Saturday at live obsessive I
know that it was a real bucket list
moment finally host the show back in
2021 what can you share about the
processor mechanics that go into putting
together a monologue because yours did
seem particularly personal yeah
um and they did say it was like Steve
Higgins I think is one who came up to me
and said he was like there's usually
when the host comes in especially if
it's their first time there's usually
one thing that they just focus on it's
like either a sketch thing
or something else but with half the
people it's the monologue and that was
the thing I couldn't
I stressed out about that more than
anything else because it was personal I
had some idea I threw up some idea that
I can't remember now what it was and
then they came back with the good nights
because of this whole moment where Kevin
Nealon picks you up and I said actually
remember that so well at the time being
like picking him up pick me up I want to
go up too
um
so that the writers came up with that
concept and it was a lot of back and
forth and I just wasn't looking at the
sketches because I was just doing that
which is why it's just way too much to
try to catch up on so I just focused on
the monologue and in the end I was
pretty pleased with it just like even
just the showing the clip and the fact
that it was really was almost exactly 30
years to the day it was like 30 years
and two weeks or something like that so
since my brother had hosted
[Music]
the label it looks like he's holding a
cocky let's do it
you know I think because I'm searching
my lips are actually finally like warm I
think it's from the one before the ghost
pepper okay growth
good thing you're not filming this
well I'm also make I'm making a mess
over here too by the way I am I always
have the grossest place setting at a
restaurant
and I I realized that when I first
started dating my wife and like she's
really beautiful and like I'm like it
was like for the very first time it's
very self-conscious I was like 29 I'm
like have I always been this way am I a
disgusting eater and I've been paying
attention like I'm gross at one point
can I see your napkins you looked up
does this like little thing in the
corner and I went I said look at this
and I held it up and it was just covered
in sauce and as it was only up the
waiter came by took it out and gave me a
new one like oh [__] I'm disgusting
but you know what she married you she
did look at you Karen yeah regretting it
I'm sure she is
trying too hard with that name their
dreams of calypso
mushroom Mayhem boom guy with a big [__]
big mushroom [__] gum I am looking man I
didn't even think about it didn't think
twice
it's lovely coming in
the only one I haven't taken a second
bite of was this one
and I did like it though
and probably the next one but I guess
we'll see this is the one
and it's the only one you haven't
changed now yeah all right that's that's
the key that's that's the lasting power
if you're a hot sauce maker on hot ones
make the most disgusting hot sauce
scientifically possible and we'll keep
it on there for 20 Seasons we will keep
it on there baby
Christ and also that was the first one
that I felt was hot yeah that one I can
feel
there in the tongue
you've joked in the past that the only
time you ever really feel confident is
when you're showing off your Nintendo
skills do you have a definitive Mount
Rushmore of classic Nintendo games
classic just NES cartridge uh yeah uh
Castlevania is number one play it all
the time beat that [__] in like 15
minutes when I rediscovered the game in
my teens I like accidentally it's like
it's a level where you you have to go
all the way to one end go up a staircase
and go like this whereas I just went to
jump and I got hit by an enemy and it
bumped me up there and it had to skip
that whole thing and I can do it
consistently every single time it's the
little Medusa head that goes like this
you just time it out right get bumped up
I don't even remember what the rest of
that level looks like
it's a game I [__] hate it as a kid
and love now uh Castlevania 2 Simon's
Quest you remember that one
that sucked as a kid because you can't
actually play the game without having to
buy the guidebook the game makes no
sense unless you have the guidebook
there's like a part where you get to the
end of the level there's just a wall
Mike Tyson's punch out
um which looks good
[Music]
top one to beat and you have to play
that on an old school too you can't you
can't play Tyson on an HD tv the the
timing is just it's like half a second
off because you know he blinks before he
throws the uppercut that's going to kill
you you have to play it on an old too
there was a bar fools that had a little
promotion it was like on Thursdays or
something to play it there right yeah
and they had they had a little it was up
in the corner too cold like this beer if
you can beat Tyson and uh they said we
have the cheat code I was like no no I
know it and I know the cheat code only
by sound
I don't I know I know it like ends in
007 I think or starts with Devolution
but I know it's boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom
and then you then you just be Tyson
that's no big difference and then get a
free pitcher of beer and get that get
free pitcher of beer which
would maybe come in handy right now it
probably would this next one is the bomb
Beyond insanity
pass
I've seen people on your show do these
like [__] little nibble
Here Comes
[Music]
all right let's go I'm excited
that was not a nibble no version no big
deal oh [__] you're right that doesn't
taste good at all
all right
that doesn't taste good no
I didn't want to swallow that all right
I get I understand I shouldn't shoot it
longer I understand what you're saying
entirely
I just try to rip through it you know
yeah that's like the the sooner I meet
the experience the sooner I'll be done
with the experience you know oh my God
right you've done that 230 some odd
times now yeah probably closer to 300.
[__] your mother
did you do that anyway that was fun no
problem no problem oh
yeah it's crazy there was like nothing
until yeah you know that was so that's
such a misleading yeah it doesn't seem
that long we were like talking about a
nice little head high you know and then
this comes in
reversing a lot the whole thing
let me ask you please
under these uh under these trying
circumstances can you recall step by
step how to make your grilled cheese
you're like drunk midnight snack grilled
cheese have you heard about this this is
like monster and you get this yeah man I
just [__] made it up it was actually
there was this Deli you used to go to my
friend
drunk and we would just tell him to make
sandwiches and we would throw out
different ingredients and this one time
I threw it out so good I made it at home
it was monster with mushrooms that I
sauteed with butter and teriyaki sauce
put it on the monster and then you put a
bunch of like garlic salt and garlic
powder on the butter that you make the
grilled cheese with
very good my favorite drunk sandwich uh
was
I said I don't like tuna sandwich that's
they had the best best tuna you put
whatever the [__] you want you put like
Brie salami I want that I want tuna Brie
salami [__] good man tuna Brie salami
tuna Brie salami it's a good sandwich
throw some basil there and some honey
mustard
I came prepared with my
kleenexes
oh wow you are [__] fired yeah no I
get it I get it
the worst is over
Stone Cold Steve Austin dude I didn't
watch his yeah actually amazing I love
stone cold I love Stone Cold
um he was uh I think I'm losing Hearing
in my ear you know
I hear a ringing I hear a ringing like a
lot of that sort of thing you know wow
he strikes me as someone who could deal
with hot sauce
all right
do people like you after the show
so it's actually an interesting question
it goes all over the map you know yeah
sometimes there's people like you and I
are gonna have a talk after this kind of
situation like when we reach that point
in the show that'll happen every once in
a while but then even
there we go
that sounds good I was actually cooling
down the bomb right I have to say the
bomb [__] you with your shitty name Da
Bomb [__]
one of the great compliments I ever got
about this show is after Seth Rogen's
episode he goes
famous person hot you know like I said
yeah it's like actually [__] up show
yeah
but there ends up sometimes being kind
of a trauma Bond situation where then
like we become like friends you know
like no matter no matter where it slides
and goes sideways emotionally over the
course of this thing when we get to the
Finish Line it's usually with a hug you
know what I'm saying I get that I'm
actually I want to go back to
this one because it's the only one I
haven't finished and I need to cool down
my mouth some more so I am cheating but
whatever no no
well that's lovely that's like a scoop
of ice cream actually
yeah it's like swinging a bat with like
a donut on it you know and then you take
that weight off you're like [__] I'm
strong yeah
that's off
eat my ship
so I loved reading about this event that
you do with the succession writer it's
called Dangerous bangers where you guys
all screen movies that are bangers but
it's dangerous because you don't really
remember if they were bangers or not
yeah what was it about Kurt Russell's
80s action film Big Trouble in Little
China why did you pull that and then how
did it hold up on a repeat we'll see
that movie is great and I've heard
people say have you seen it lately no
why I'll just leave it
um but that's why it's a dangerous
Banger that's why I've been told like LA
Story I haven't seen since I was a kid
I've been told that once that one's
dangerous because I've heard mixed
things about that uh you want to know I
have a friend who uh recently watched
Goodfellas for the first time didn't
watch it when it came out so it heard
all this hype and was like that movie's
terrible I'm like [__] you that movie's
amazing I've seen it like eight times
when's the last time you saw it I'm like
yeah whatever 20 years ago and then he
just gave his review on it and based on
his review I was like oh my God does
that movie suck I'm never gonna see that
movie again I'm leaving that as a happy
memory but I feel like when I brought
that up people like no that's not a
dangerous manger you can revisit that
that's just a banger I think so I the
one thing I remember about is him saying
like they call him Tony two times
because he always says everything good
times I'm gonna go get the babies get
the papers I'm like yeah that sounds
awful when you say it like out of
context like that
all right how much are you putting on
this [__]
all right
don't let it Avalanche but is this
that's too much
well wherever you go is where I go [__]
I don't know
we dig our own grapes yeah
there it is Cheers Cheers Karen
[Music]
yeah should have told me to put Less on
there
[Music]
and the good news is okay
okay
you invited me on the show that's true
[Music]
all right there we go all right
so the good news is the wings their
distant memory all right but we're still
not too distant have a little bit left
to go on this stress test of hot ones
okay we're gonna put you to the test a
little bit but you do because one of the
things that you credit with being a
childhood actor is your ability to
memorize lines quickly are you about to
test me insane
it's almost like a parlor trick I can
look at a speech like once or twice and
I can repeat it back pretty quickly
you're gonna test me but my guess is
you've never done that under the stress
of being slow roasted in hot sauce so it
feel humor Us God we have a little
monologue
let it soak
to this gross abuse
okay
I'll give it a shot all right
[Music]
all right Loosely uh
blind
you're a sadistic lunatic don't I was
kidding
you are a sadistic lunatic John Evans
I know
that you think I'm a sexy beast and
that's why you brought me here was so
that you could look deep in my Soulful
eyes and watch me tear up as I ate the
bomb
uh but I think you're a lovely man uh
but I am married so past is that close
and scene nail look at you Karen Culkin
taking on the wings of death living to
tell the tale and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life I don't know
nothing whatever I probably have stuff
and things but uh I got wings and hot
sauce in my belly that's my immediate
future and uh
yeah I'm gonna try to go home and parent
after this this is gonna be fun
there was a word summoned in there
it was like you are a you're a sadistic
lunatic Sean Evans these hot sauces are
something from the bowels of hell and I
will avenge this gross abuse of my taste
buds trust me I'm going to put the bomb
in your eyeballs
the sun don't shine that's my promise to
you Mr spice Lord or whatever I'm pretty
sure it was a sexy thing where you were
flirting with me yeah
oh why
God bomb
that was the biggest mistake that was
terrible it's awful idea what'd you do
why'd you do that
because you're a dick
I'm never coming back
you're right
good good job
hello I'm camera guy Bill
[Music]
I'm the kind of cowboy who likes to
sausage wings but I need a brand new
flavor to make these tastes insane
plastic chili Maple that's rolling down
the line All Aboard it's Canadian time
would you look at that coming around the
bend a dash chili frizzles from smoking
and sauce is loose runaway Caboose
hotter than a babe on a moose or a great
northern Sable chocolate classic chill
and maple made with real maple syrup
make you eat on your stirrups
yeah
first and face got the Tweet hey Get on
Up and Dance on your feet first and face
got the sweet heat Get on Up and Dance
on your feet sweet and refreshing to
keep your senses guessing with the tiny
apple cider tons of [__] Rodeo Riders
whoa
let's open the hockey Tonks just but go
and get permission from your mom go to
heatness.com
[Music]
for a Great Northern State we'll try
that classic chili maple
[Music]
for a great northern Stapleton classic
chili maple
let's do it
y'all come back now
[Music]